how did you have never become involved
with the project to see co-producer he's
now the Purdue a producer we upped him
from co-producer to producer when he
came through with all our music rights
in the end yes the balance of what was
owed on the music rights he picked up
and allowed us to finish the film we
first got involved with him when after
Mike Green did the original fund of the
original seven minutes I was sending it
out to major people in the industry and
one of the people I said it too was herb
alpert who had funded my blacklist film
partially funded that and so I told him
I was doing another documentary and
would he be interested and he took a
look at the seven minutes and called me
and said we will give you a matching
grant so he did a very generous matching
grant and then I had to go out I had one
year to match it and then he went out
and I had to go out and get the matching
money so I didn't know where I was going
to get matching grant for seventy five
thousand dollars so but I was on the
board of the I da and Sandra Roush who
was the the then executive of the ID a
board I asked her you know you've been
around this a long time who do you think
might be interested in funding this and
she said you know you have no Mike
because he's got this big jazz festival
and he certainly loves women so he seems
like a natural and she put me in touch
with his associate who dick Rosen swag
who brought the project a half and they
immediately came on board so that was
the fundraiser that you did how did that
happen it was at the moment yes well
when we got to the point where we had to
raise the money for our music rights I
just didn't know which way to turn so I
called dick up and I said listen we need
to do some kind of fundraiser to raise
the money for the music rights
and do you think that half might be
willing to do something up at the
it I mean after all he is the
co-producer he was just co-producer at
that time and he said well let me ask
him and of course half said yes we went
up there and we did a fundraiser and in
a small theater they had there and we
raised about half the music rights and
then at the end I had to start going out
and beating on the other doors again and
trying to get the rest of the music
rights and so one of the doors that I be
done was half's again I i think i sent
out an email to my top ten funders and
said this is the letter i hoped i never
would have to send you but we now are at
a stopping place we cannot release the
film until we pay for the music rights
and then a couple of people came back to
me with something and then half came in
and said all right how much more do you
need and I told him and he said okay
we'll cover it and he did and voila we
were on our way so now he's the producer
we can't thank him enough he's been so
wonderful so supportive and you know has
never had any kind of hand on never had
anything told us anything to do with the
film just you know go make your film so
that's the best best kind of partner you
could have
you